chapter 16
is on constrained least squares that's
an extension of least squares that allow
it that's going to allow us to add
linear equality constraints to a least
squares problem
and that really actually pulls together
uh kind of the two things you know how
to do
solve linear equations number one and
number two least squares and this this
will actually
select the common parent of both of them
okay
so we'll start with defining what the
problem is and we'll talk a little bit
about the nomenclature and that sort of
thing okay
so here is the uh linearly constrained
least squares problem we're going to
call that cls for constrained least
squares
and it's this it's an optimization
problem and it is described this way
it's minimize the norm of ax minus b
squared now by the way that alone by
itself is simply
the least squares problem but then we
have this
subject to see x equals d
now the variable here which is the thing
that we want to find or
solve for or something or compute at
some point is this n vector
x so that's what this means now
what this objective what this constraint
means the semantics of it is this it's
is that we
we would like this to be small so the
smaller norm ax minus b
squared is the happier we are the
constraint
says basically we will not consider
any x that does not satisfy it so if
someone comes along and says hey how
about this x
if c x is not equal to d we're not
interested
okay if cx e is equal to d then
it's that we say that that point is
feasible and then we'd say okay now then
tell me the objective and then of course
if we have two of two of these and
they're both feasible
one has a lower objective than the other
we prefer that one
so that's the semantics of an
optimization problem and this is kind of
a standard form
for describing one um i should say that
these these are this is not me
this is not mathematical notation um
sorry these are not like mathematical
operators like min
min is a mathematical function that
takes a finite number of
real numbers and simply gives you the
smallest of them
so this is actually really what we're
doing is we're describing an
optimization problem
okay so here the
matrix a is m by n uh b of b
of course must be a an m vector
c is a p by n matrix and sometimes
people would say this problem has
p linear equality constraints and the
and the uh the vector d is of course a p
vector
and these are called problem data uh the
idea is that they're given
right so you you know them your job is
to find x but you know
a b c and d okay now
uh norm squared of ax minus b that's
called the objective function
um so that's that you've already seen
that that's the objective function
um cx equals d people would describe as
the equality constraints
uh so and it says basically we will not
consider
an any x that does not satisfy c x
equals d
okay now what does it mean to be a
solution of this problem to solve this
problem
what we mean is two things number one
we'll say that the vector x hat is a
solution if it must be feasible it must
satisfy c
x hat equals d that's the point of the
problem
and the following is true um for any
vector
x that satisfies a that satisfies cx
equals d so for any other feasible
vector
the objective of the point we are
proposing x hat
has to be less than or equal to the
other one and that's it so
it is the best in terms of lowest it's
the least
objective point among
all feasible points that's one way to
say it
okay so
what's kind of cool about it is it
combines uh solving least squares
problems i mean because part
part of it i mean that's just that's
this part is just least squares right
here
um and then subject to a set of linear
equations so it kind of
glues together these the solving linear
equations with at least with a least
squares problem
um another way a very good way to think
of it also is it's a bi-criterion
problem
uh it's sort of in the limit of lambda
going to infinity in other words
if i were to form the by criterion
problem
that looks and i'm going to scalarize it
now so it looks like this
right that's my objective now the
meaning of this is that
we'll allow cx to not equal d but we're
going to penalize you for it
now as lambda goes to infinity that
basically
is telling us that you you have
your only choice is to have cx equals d
and so
we would expect um when lambda goes to
infinity
this just basically uh you know by
uh by objective least squares is going
to give you a solution
of the constrained least squares problem
the cls problem here
okay um now we're going to find out that
in fact
um you can uh we're going to find out
that there's a direct method
to solve directly the constrained least
squares problem but nevertheless this is
not a bad way to think of it
it is something like a bi objective
least squares problem
as the weight on the second one goes to
infinity which causes it to basically
become
an equality constraint
so we'll look at a quick example we are
going to
fit let's say some data or whatever
or points to a so-called piecewise
polynomial
a piecewise means that you chunk up the
function into uh this is a function
on r a scalar function so it says you
it's
you you uh you you chunk up r into um
intervals and then on each interval the
function has you know
the particular form possibly different
coefficients so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say that f hat is going to be the
polynomial p
when x is less than some number a a is
sometimes called the not
point in in such a model or
it's equal to q of x and they're both
just cubic
they're just cubic polynomials okay but
we're going to add some constraints now
and the constraints are going to say
that we want number one we want f hat to
be continuous and that means that
when we evaluate you know when you jump
from a little bit
less than a to a little bit more than a
we want to make sure that the function
value is the same
and so that would be this constraint p
of a is q of a
and the other thing is we're going to
ask for the derivative to be continuous
um
by the way we could also get the second
derivative to be to be continuous there
if we want it
um and so this this these are our
requirements
by the way when you have a piecewise
polynomial and you make
constraints on der how many derivatives
must match at each not point
the resulting function is called a
spline so that's something you'll you'll
almost certainly be hearing and
whatever you end up doing you're going
to hear about splines and so this would
be a cubic spline of some kind i forget
what kind of people i forget how people
call it um
okay so what we're going to do now is
we're going to fit
uh f hat to some data x i y i um and
we'll minimize uh
the the the sum square error and we're
just going to express that as a
constrained least squares problem so
this is going to be our
our that's going to be of course our
objective and these are going to turn
into that's going to turn into our cx
equals d part the linear
equations or linear constraints part of
the problem
let me just show you how it works first
so there's some
data points scattered here here's the
number a
and the blue shows you p and the red
shows you
q um and what you can see here
is okay well number one it we solved it
we'll see how to do that later
um you solved it and actually sure
enough they the
all of the all both the blue p
and the red q fit the given data pretty
well
but the really cool part is this um
number one they match up at a
that's one of our constraints and the
second one is their derivative is the
same
at a so that's uh so and this is what it
would do
if i didn't do this right the the red
curve could go up like that and the blue
curve like that and there'd be a jump
there
um so that that that would be my by
imposing this constraint i'm avoiding
that jump
okay so let's see how to actually put
that problem into
that standard cls form um
well the constraints are
p of a equals q of a
that's p of a and this is minus q of a
right so that's what that is and it just
says they're equal to zero so p of a
minus q of a equals zero
and then this expression here
is p prime of a because you know just
p prime is this polynomial theta one
plus theta two a plus theta oh sorry
theta one plus theta two x plus theta
two three x squared
and you take the derivative and you get
this so this is
that is this thing right here that is
literally
that is p prime of a and
this thing here is minus
q prime of a okay and
so if we look at this we'll see that
this we could write
these two equations as c times theta
equals d
theta is the eighth vector of parameters
a c would have
two rows right so in our in our
constrained least squares problem over
here
c we'd have uh p is two
and that means that there would be two
linear constraints and in fact you could
even annotate them
the first one says continuity
continuity at the not point and the
second one would say continuous
derivative
at the not point okay
so that's that and of course the
prediction error
is is easy to do uh i mean it's
the what you do is it's simply a i
transpose theta minus y i
and ai is going to be either is is is
one of these two things because you're
selecting
which polynomial you evaluate to to fit
the model
and then the sum square error is a theta
minus y norm squared so
this would this means we could we can
easily
form we can put this immediately into
this constrained least squares
for constrained least squares problem
format
now we don't yet know how to solve that
problem but we will i mean later you
you'll uh you'll have some code or it's
going to be very short
it just gives you the solution of this
you get you pass in
a b c d what comes out is the solution
that's it okay so we'll that's that's
coming up
before though we um before we jump into
you know how you solve it we want to
look at a special case which is actually
fairly important it's called the least
norm problem it's just a special case
it's a special case when a equals i and
b equals zero and so basically the
problem looks like this
it says find me you know this is
a x minus b but a is the identity b is 0
so it's just norm x squared
so this says minimize the sum of the
square and find the
minimize the sum of the squares of the
components of x subject to x satisfying
c equals d c x equals d now
geometrically that means
find the smallest vector that satisfies
a set of linear
equations so it's very interesting
usually in many applications
somehow this the size of x will is this
will translate into something like
find me the most efficient solution or
something like that that's typically
what it means
then that's and this works of course
when there's many many solutions of c
x equals d
let's look at an example of that um very
simple example
so i have a unit mass on a frictionless
surface um
and it's initially at rest and then what
we're going to do is we're going to have
a 10 vector
f and what it does is we're going to
apply to that mass
of force on it each one for one second
so we'll apply the force
f1 in newtons to this mass for one
second
right at one second we're going to
switch to the force f2 and that sort of
stuff
now if you'd like to know what the uh
final position and velocity are after 10
the full 10 seconds it's this the
velocity
is just the sum of the forces right
because if i apply one newton to a one
kilogram mass for one second
it acquires a speed of one
right so which is you know that's fine
and if i apply
a force f1 it requires a speed f1
okay so so it's actually the sum of the
forces gives you
the final velocity okay
the position uh you can work it out it's
not it's not very hard but it's equal to
this it's
it's uh you know it's like nine and a
half times f1
you know uh i guess that is eight and a
half
uh times f2 and so on and only a half of
f10
right by the way um you might ask
yourself
why is that that's weird right and the
answer is really simple when i apply a
for the first force i apply
i end up giving the mass a velocity but
it keeps that velocity for the rest
for the rest for the remaining nine
seconds that's why
that works right and so that first in
some ways that first
that first force i apply is much more uh
efficient right in terms of how far you
get
if that's your goal it's very right
whereas the last force you apply
is right up to the last and that that
only gives you a half okay
so anyway these are this is easy to
derive
all right um now here's what we want to
do
i would like to find a force sequence
which moves which causes the final
velocity of the mass to be zero
and it's positioned to be one so very
simple this is actually kind of we're
literally it's called in control it's
called transferring the mass so the mass
is sitting here
at at position zero velocity zero and
after ten seconds
i i need it to be one meter to the right
that's what i'm taking one to mean
one meter to the right and and it should
be stationary
there okay so that's that's my that's my
job okay
now there's a ton of four sequences that
do that
um rough i mean here's a simple example
right if you apply a one newton
uh force so you you push it real hard
it'll accelerate after one second uh
to a speed of one meter per second right
it'll have a
it'll have gone half the distance right
then
then i instantly switch the force to
instead of full pushing to full pulling
now i pull the mass
for the next seconds and all i'm doing
is i'm bleeding off the vlog the speed
i'm bleeding off the velocity and so
what happens is
over the next half second the velocity
goes right down to zero
write it right at the end of two seconds
the velocity is zero
oh and the position is one because i
also move another half uh
half a meter so i'm actually right where
i want to be after two seconds and then
i just sit tight and that means apply
zero force
for the next eight seconds now of course
what that means
is that um i mean if you apply zero
force
to something that's you know zero
velocity zero position
it just sits there okay so this is this
is this is called um bang bang because
the force goes up to a large value
then switch instantly down to the
negative of that okay
and this comes up in a bunch of uh in a
bunch of different uh
things okay so but there's lots of other
f's
so here is the bang bang four sequence
and here's the position over time right
so this is
it makes perfect sense like kind of how
do you move something from here to here
first you push it
um to get it going then
that's this part right and then you uh
you pull you you you pull on it uh to
bleed the speed off so that when it
arrives at the
at the final target position it's um
it is uh you know it's stationary it has
velocity zero
oh i should mention something just for
fun um
here are required we're we're using the
requirements with that
that v final equals zero uh so um
but there are applications where this is
not there
okay so um i'll
give you a rough idea about that if
someone well okay i can tell you exactly
where this comes up
um if this is something like a missile
then
or a bomb right then then
what someone says is uh yeah get me to
the target um
you say yeah give me the target you
don't like sure no problem and then you
say by the way when you arrive at the
target what speed would you like to be
going they're like uh it doesn't matter
okay so um roughly speaking when you
see um optimization problems where
the final target specifies the position
but not the velocity
um generally speaking these are not
socially positive applications
but they have them obviously i just
thought i'd mention that
okay um what we're going to do now is
we're going to find
the least norm for sequence so this is
this is a solution of the problem i mean
it's just we're satisf
this this f satisfies our
our equation which is just c f equals d
now d just happens to be um you know one
zero
okay zero one sorry go zero one
okay but that's so this is one one
solution of this
very much um under specified or
underdetermined
uh linear equation but we're gonna see
another one and notice just remember the
number it's one newton and minus one
newton
um what we're going to do now is set
this up and find
the if you like the gentlest force
that transfers a mass one meter
uh in you know over 10 seconds the
gentlest force
and we'll define gentle by the sum of
the squares of the forces
right um okay so
here we end up solving this very
specific least norm problem
right here and you can understand
everything here
uh the first one the first equation is
telling you the sum of the f's should be
zero that's the one that says that when
you arrive at the at the target position
you should be
uh you have velocity zero and the second
one says you'll actually make it to the
target
okay now it turns out
that when we work out what that is now
you can work it out analytically but
there's no reason to do that you just
use the methods we're going to talk
about later and you can do it
numerically
but here's what happens you end up with
a a norm
squared of of the solution of this being
point zero one
two one um that is compared
to the bang bang one has a norm squared
of
two because it's one newton and then
it's minus one newton you square those
and add them
you get uh two okay so
this is what is that 200 times
you know quote gentler it's it's
basically you're applying a force that
is if you care about mean
the sum of the squares of the forces
it's 200 times smaller
that's not surprising right because you
obviously could do it a whole lot more
gently
than you know uh excel you know uh
you know giving it a big accelerator and
besides we're wasting this
this thing gets you there in two steps
but i gave you ten so
okay so it's not surprising um now let's
look at that force
um here's the force and and here we go
we go from position 0
to position 10. um notice completely
different scale that's 0.05 and minus
0.05
if you remember the bang bang uh 4
sequence
that was plus 1 newton and minus 1
newton so this is 20 times smaller
sorry starts 20 times smaller and then
gets even smaller still
here's the interesting thing um you know
bang bang looked like this on a
completely different scale it would look
like this and then switch over
you know switch down to here right this
would be a plus one
and minus one um but what you can see
here is pretty cool what it does is it
starts by pushing it
you know 0.05 which is a whole lot less
than 1.05 newton
then on the next step it's a little bit
less a little bit less a little bit less
and then
right at t equals five is when you
switch over from
uh a small push to a small pole and then
you pull a little harder and a little
harder still
and so and and then by the time you get
to the end uh you're
you're you're pulling uh it's
symmetrical it's like
you know minus 0.05 you're pulling by
0.05 newtons roughly
okay and then and here is the trajectory
right and it's it's actually kind of
cool nice and smooth
so people use um force trajectories like
this like
all the time i mean this is very very
common uh is to use these things
because you can generate beautiful nice
smooth
force trajectories so that that is kind
of the
the idea okay so uh now we haven't yet
said
uh how to solve a a uh constrained least
squares problem or a least norm problem
uh that's going to be our next topic